[Music]
the pursuit of a remarkable achievement
what a journey that is to watch
[Applause]
I knew from the moment I met LeBron that
he had the ability and the courage to
reach those amazing Heights
and he has
[Music]
to witnessed him breaking This Record is
truly remarkable and I wanted to sit
down with him and ask him just what it
means to him and what it means to his
legacy how are you hey what's up man how
are you buddy one of my favorites good
to seeing you yes sir you know look you
walking up
before we get to a bunch of stuff you
look unbeliever I appreciate it no I
mean how much you're like 15 yeah I
leaned out leaned out you know just
trying to um you know with all the miles
that I you know
I've accomplished in over the seasons
and years and playing and stuff trying
to figure out how I can keep my body
going yeah terrific you keep uh being
great so yeah LeBron James era is
underway
[Applause]
the youngest player to reach five
thousand ten thousand twenty five
thousand and one thirty thousand points
[Applause]
all-time scoring record now belongs to
LeBron James
most points
in the history of the game and I know
what a historian you are about what does
that mean it's so crazy coach because I
mean obviously I play you know for you a
couple times in our Olympic runs and
um I never like sought out to account I
know that you're like I've always ever
since I was a kid and my little league
coaches always talked about the beauty
of the past and the beauty of everybody
filling in a good Rhythm and everybody
feeling like they're important to the
wind
I've always
knew that I had a a god-given ability
but I wanted to use that for my
teammates
[Music]
for me to sit here as the all-time
leader in points scored it's like
it's mind-boggling because I never saw
well it's
look
it hasn't been broken since Jabbar
[Applause]
has accomplished something that I don't
think will ever happen again you've been
great for two decades and so what did
how did the definition of great change
along the way for you I think coaching
at the end and obviously you know this
as well I think for me
paying respect to the history of the
game yeah you've always sung and and I I
when I first knew that I wanted to play
the game of basketball I would go to the
local library but I would always read
about the likes of like you know Jerry
West and Oscar Robinson and some of the
grace Kareem Abdul-Jabbar Will
Chamberlain tiny Archibald Larry Bird
and all those guys and Magic Johnson I
would read about the history of the game
and I knew right then and there that
in order for those guys to be great it
had to be somebody before them that
inspired them right you know so I looked
for someone in the Sports World you know
being an underprivileged kid in the
inner city of Akron Ohio for inspiration
so I looked for a couple people and one
was Michael Jordan
my job
another one was Ken Griffey Jr yeah and
Deion Sanders you know I love sports and
those guys
not only played at an exceptional talent
and exceptional level they also
they had a joy you know so I just always
said if I had any opportunity to be able
to play this game
I have to commit to it
[Applause]
your career kind of mirrors the growth
of social media so you're also
scrutinized so handling all all of that
how has that been that's that's one of
the biggest challenges as well coach I
mean um I always wanted to
one of the first high school games we
never recruited
no why did you why you didn't record
well because I knew you weren't coming
but you're a smart man
I'm a honorary I'm honorary Dookie
at any time anytime anytime tell me
about the expectation no I think you
know I came up in an era where out I was
right there at the beginning of
High School nationally televised games
has to
[Applause]
[Music]
fight
my senior year you know I was on ESPN
and playing the number one team in the
country and I
I was like oh this is this landscape is
going to change and and I have to be
ready for it you know and also you know
my my Junior and Senior year I barely
played in our high school Arena our our
high school moved our games to the
University of Akron
so then I was I started to think as a 16
17 year old I was like oh this is the
business as well
you know I said okay they want more
people in the stands be more concession
me more tickets me more people oh it's a
business so I was at the start of like
the social media airport and at the
start of the business and I'm learning
at 17 years old
that helped me to when I got drafted
to you know the NBA I was kind of
already kind of fast tracked on what to
become understanding like yes this is
fun this is the NBA this is your dream
to understand they're social there's
business that goes along with this too
so you have to always be conscientious
of that James has an every night
pressure that no one else has probably
the most anticipated debut of any first
year athlete in any sport look I've
coached for almost five decades so
youngsters coming into our program feel
a great deal of pressure but it's not
nearly the amount of pressure that was
on LeBron for many years this franchise
was looking for a savior what he was
talking about he was going to be one of
the greatest of all times it's a lot of
pressure to put on a high school kid to
go from high school and being the number
one pick and being that age 18 was no
pressure oh
it's no pressure at all I've been
getting pressure since I was 10 years
old I know how to play the game of
basketball and that's what I will fall
back on I don't really get involved into
the whole pressure thing he's not only
the number one pair but he gets picked
by his home team so he's the Savior he's
still a teenager I'm not afraid of
failure I'm not afraid to step back I
really want to let this franchise up I'm
just really excited about
being a Cavalier wearing that wine and
goat
so when you were that age and you are
already people saying you're great by
the way when did you get the chosen one
tattoo I got that after
after my rookie year in the NBA so it
wasn't in high school no but it was a
magazine a local magazine my sophomore
year actually used that on one of the
Clippers after one of my games they was
like is this kid The Chosen you know and
I I was like oh that's that's pretty
cool I mean
I don't know if I am but it sounds cool
so I love that one I don't know if you
remember one time I saw in the locker
room I said that's a cool tattoo I'm
gonna go do you remember what you told
me yeah so you get the chosen too no no
you said coach there's only one chosen
one oh yeah well there it is and you
might have been him I should have took
it off
so great at that time like like for me
somebody Great's overused and in your
case it's I think under use but by
making some of the decisions you you
have Cleveland to Miami
you go back to Cleveland
to go to La it puts a lot of pressure on
you yeah yeah it's a win yeah did you do
that on purpose or what was your
thinking well I mean the obviously going
to Miami was was
the most pressure I've ever felt on
behalf of all of South Florida thank you
welcome
just going on here and teaming up with D
Wade's greatness and teaming up with box
I love those guys yeah yeah great God I
love those guys forever and so you know
to be able to go down there and
accomplish what we wanted to accomplish
winning you know multiple championships
that was that was huge let the
coronation begin LeBron James has helped
Crown Miami
the Miami Heat have won the 2013 NBA
title and then this it was a it was a
part of me in my stomach that felt like
I had not accomplished or or reached my
goal back in Cleveland so I went back
there with a with a lot of expectation
I'm a dude
[Applause]
I'm teaming up with Kyrie Kyrie but he's
his start yeah he's starting he's young
and you know he's very ambitious and but
I could see the talent in him and having
Kevin Love who's such a you know great a
great pickup for us it did become a lot
of pressure
um of trying to
end a 52-year drought of
um winning a championship and being able
to accomplish that that was the hardest
to be so emotional that was the hardest
one
[Applause]
I'm back from 3-1 versus that joggernaut
of a team in Golden state with the great
Steph and Clayton Draymond and all those
guys
and then go to LA to add more pressure
to myself of just the legacy of the
Lakers in general it's been a long time
to Champions
[Applause]
much more of that conversation still to
come there is LeBron who has been the
All-Star game MVP three times the record
is four held by Bob Pettit Kobe